hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear my little movie review
series here are some weird noises in the
background uh it's just rain you know
florida and summer y'all so anyway let's
get started so all right i can't
remember exactly how i ended up first
hearing about this movie which is called
broadcast signal intrusion and it came
out back in
2021 now the title i guess like must
have stuck in my mind because as soon as
i was like scrolling through my amazon
prime like the free to me horror section
and i saw it pop up on there i was kind
of like oh i think i heard about that or
something i couldn't like remember where
but i was like oh i kind of felt
compelled to like watch it
now at first i thought that i had heard
about it because you remember like
back a while ago um we did a show about
like creepy youtube videos like sort of
iconic creepy ones
and i was like oh well because this
movie kind of has a little bit of that
going on in it we're actually like a lot
of that going on it i was like oh i must
have heard it mentioned in relation to
that but then i looked up and we did
that creepy youtube show like way the
[ __ ] back in october of 2020 and this
movie didn't come out until well it
premiered at south by southwest in march
of 2021 and then it came out in like
wide release in october of 21. so it
couldn't have been research into that
that like you know made me think of this
movie so i have no idea like where i
first heard of this but for whatever
reason like the title of it or the image
of the cover or something like that
stuck in my mind because i was kind of
like oh yeah i got to see that i heard
about it so i don't know so anyway i
ended up watching it now the movie was
directed by jacob gentry now he also
co-wrote and co-directed uh the
excellent 2007 horror movie if you
haven't seen this called the signal um i
have seen it but i don't think i've
reviewed it on this channel actually i
should probably get around to doing that
uh he also did the my super psycho sweet
16 trilogy which i haven't seen and
don't appear to be on uh available at
least on dvd or uh you know i couldn't
find them on amazon i mean they're there
but they say they're unavailable so i
don't know what that's all about um i
think it's like an mtv series or movies
or something like that i don't really
know but he did that too so this movie
in particular if you kind of like horror
that's sort of like
something like a downbeat noir kind of
vibe and if you're real into plots like
involving eerie conspiracy theories
then this movie will probably be like
right up your alley um or right down
your rabbit hole in a more apt freeze
although it sounds kind of dirty i will
warn you though
that
the ending of this movie is kind of
abrupt and anticlimactic
and the mystery isn't really resolved
although i will say too in the movies
defense
that a close watch of it uh it doesn't
really spell everything out for you but
there are a lot of possible theories
if you kind of like watch it and pick up
like all the little details along the
way when i get to the end i don't really
want to spoil too much of it
but when i get to the end i might do
like a little spoiler thing and say what
i think what was going on in there but
you know we'll see when we get there so
because the thing about it is that the
point of this movie is not really and
you don't really know this going in
until the end of it and then you start
thinking about it
the point of the movie isn't really to
be like a cut and dried mystery per se
but
it's kind of more
like a psychological horror like a
psychological examination
but i can't understand that like some
viewers really like frustrated by the
end of it like what the [ __ ] like what
happened and i kind of felt like that at
first too i was just kind of like what
okay if that's how you're gonna end your
movie
but then i kept thinking about it like
because i watched it yesterday and i was
like thinking about it and i was like oh
i see what you did there okay i i know
what you're you're getting at it is a
little bit frustrating though the ending
but
it's kind of one of those movies that
probably you need a couple of watches so
if you're into real kind of i don't want
to say it's like a puzzle story kind of
but it's something that leaves a lot of
stuff to like be theorized about which
is really interesting because it's kind
of meta in the way that it examines like
why people are drawn to conspiracy
theories and then it almost kind of like
makes you want to do like your own
conspiracy theory like about this movie
and like come up with your own theories
about it which i thought was actually
pretty clever and didn't really occur to
me until like about probably like an
hour after i watched it you know what i
mean so there's that so broadcast signal
intrusion is set in chicago in 1999.
our main character is this guy named
james and he's played by harry shum jr
who most people probably recognize from
glee so james's wife hannah
mysteriously disappeared three years
prior so like in 1996
all that was found of her was her
abandoned car left on a bridge possibly
because of his grief i mean he still
hasn't gotten over it
james is a loner
and the only time he really ever
interacts with people is he goes to this
presumably like a support group for
people that have lost love loved ones
and he does kind of interact with one
woman there but other than that not so
much he kind of like keeps to himself
and he seems to have found the ideal job
for his kind of like reclusive
proclivities i guess he works in the
basement of this chicago tv station
and he his job is archiving all their
old broadcasts and like for their
library you know what i mean
now his interactions with his boss or
his supervisor who you never see are
conducted entirely through post-it notes
which
to me i was like wow this is my ideal
job too i never have to see another
[ __ ] person and people just if you
want something leave me a note
like just leave me alone the rest of the
time sweet so like i could understand
that because like i said i'm kind of one
of those people like the less or the
fewer people that i have to interact
with like on a daily basis like the
happier i am generally so one day when
he's archiving old footage which is his
job obviously
james stumbles across this bizarre
what they call a broadcast signal
intrusion and it was something that
interrupted a local newscast back in
1987.
if you've ever seen the real life a very
iconic viral creepy video which is
called i feel fantastic with the uh tara
the android like kind of like going
around like singing and stuff
you'll understand like the vibe of what
this video looks like i mean it's
clearly very influenced by i feel
fantastic
uh so the short clip that he finds that
interrupted the broadcast for you know
several seconds or whatever it was it
has like a either a person and a mask or
could be an android and they're kind of
like open and closing in their mouth and
like swaying back and forth they're kind
of in this weird
room that maybe isn't like a whole
entire room
and all kind of like there's all kind of
these weird like disturbing like
distorted sounds like going on in the
background so james gets curious about
this as you would and he starts to do
like some perfunctory research on a one
of the old school like bbs message
boards because like i said this is set
in 1999
and from this research he discovers that
there was actually another similar
intrusion that occurred the same year
like a month or two later something like
that during the broadcast of a sci-fi
show called don kronos now
the show don kronos
is
this movie universe's version of doctor
who
and the reason that they're doing that
is because all of this is a very direct
reference to a real life event which
maybe a lot of you watching will have
heard of uh it was called the max
headroom signal hijacking
in which some as yet identified person
broke into the broadcast of two chicago
tv stations one time during a newscast
and one time during a doctor who episode
and the guy or girl was wearing a max
headroom mask was kind of like swaying
around being weird and like maybe like i
think the second one they were talking
about coca-cola or some [ __ ] like that
so it was like really weird and it's one
of the most famous like unsolved like
signal intrusions like of all time and i
feel like most people that have lived on
the internet for any length of time have
heard about it but that's what this is
directly referencing why it's set in
chicago why there's a sci-fi show why it
was a newscast so they did that very
deliberately so and that's one of the
things that i really liked about this
because there's actually like a lot of
references to real life events other
than that like threaded throughout the
movie and i will say too that i really
think like this whole creepy [ __ ] about
like unexplained uh youtube videos like
that are really weird are really kind of
like a fertile ground for horror because
there's always something really
unsettling about them another thing too
like another reference that i noticed in
this that i thought was really funny uh
and it's actually like it's pretty
obscure i think um you know maybe i'm
wrong about that but i've kind of
perceived it as being pretty obscure
okay in the movie like the weird i feel
fantastic-esque videos that show up in
this okay the character like the android
or the mask or something like that that
the person is
portraying in this video
is supposed to be a character
or like sort of like a janky like cheap
ass
version of of a character
that's like that's named sally sparks so
in again in the movies universe there's
this absurd like 80s sitcom called step
bot
and
the character in these videos is
supposed to be like referencing that
character like an android house wave
now this is a reference to a real life
sitcom from the 1980s which was called
small wonder in which
the dad of the main family i think
builds an android daughter i don't know
why i don't remember the reasons why he
built it i'm sure the reasons were like
nothing good because it sounds like
not really all that wholesome if i'm
being honest but i just thought that was
like kind of funny that they're actually
referencing like in the movie there's
stepbot there's an android character and
they're referencing like that real like
80s sitcom so i thought that was like
kind of entertaining so when james goes
digging back through the tv station's
archives uh to find this particular don
kronos broadcast that supposedly had the
second signal intrusion on it
he finds out that it's missing from
their library
and his boss gives him a like i guess
presumably he sends a note to his boss
about it and his boss like sends him a
note back and says oh well the tape was
confiscated by the fcc because you know
going into like a tv broadcast like
pirating into a tv broadcast was illegal
obviously um so you get the fcc you get
the fbi involved and stuff like that so
there had been an investigation and the
tape was confiscated during the course
of that investigation the boss also says
pretty much just drop it you know it's
not really that big a deal but uh james
does happen to locate a fan of the show
don kronos who had taped the episode on
betamax like back in the 80s and so he
has it so he kind of like trades it to
james
so james notices just from these two
broadcast signal intrusions so far
that the both of the intrusions
correspond with the days just before the
disappearances of two local women he
also finds out that there is a fabled
third intrusion which some people say
does not exist there's like a kind of
rumors about it
uh which was supposed to have occurred
the day before his wife vanished so he
becomes convinced that there's a
connection between all of this stuff so
he contacts one of the dudes who was
involved in the initial like fcc and fbi
investigation i guess he worked for the
fcc or he headed up the the task force
or whatever
now he goes to see the guy and the guy
insists is like look we investigated
this [ __ ] for three years we never found
the person that did it but we're pretty
convinced that we couldn't find any
connection between
these intrusions and the killer like or
kidnapper or whoever um you know we
looked into every possible lead and we
just didn't find anything so he
basically says to james you really need
to stop obsessing over this there's you
know there's nothing there but he says
something about don't go down a rabbit
hole that you can't get out of like this
is gonna ruin your life pretty much but
naturally james does not listen to
reason and he gets subsequently like
sucked deeper and deeper into the
mystery
he's pretty adamant that not only are
these you know weird intrusions like
connected to the missing women but i'm
gonna be the one to solve this even
though many people before him have tried
so along his ever unraveling journey
he comes across a whole bunch a whole
host of like weird kind of things and
people including another dude who
apparently went down the same rabbit
hole and is now kind of this crazed
homeless and suicidal guy he meets this
strange woman named alice get it uh who
follows him around for a while seemingly
for shits and giggles uh before
eventually like kind of meeting up with
him and joining him in his investigation
and you kind of meet all these really
sketchy people and like and all these
really weird situations that are left
ambiguous enough that uh when you're
watching it you're not really sure if
there's really something nefarious going
on like if there actually is a
connection between these videos and the
you know the kidnapping of the women or
the disappearance of the women or
whether james's kind of crumbling mental
state is finding patterns and
connections where there aren't any so as
i mentioned earlier uh this is actually
a really intriguing movie it has a great
premise like i said everything is like
all about creepy youtube videos and
conspiracies and [ __ ] like that it has a
really cool like noir sensibility like
even the score is like kind of a jazzy
noir-esque kind of score and like i said
the videos the videos themselves are
like super creepy like i said if you've
seen i feel fantastic like that's creepy
but this is like even creepier than that
but it's along those lines but i do
agree that i mean if you're just
watching this thinking it's gonna be
like a conspiracy and like everything's
gonna be resolved at the end then at the
end you might be like what the [ __ ] just
what the [ __ ] did i just watch and you
might get mad uh because the end is like
kind of abrupt and a lot of stuff is
kind of left unanswered um you're kind
of like well did all this stuff really
happen or was it all in james's
imagination
or something like that and i'm gonna say
i'm inclined to believe the latter that
everything i don't think everything that
happened wasn't james's imagination but
i do think like some of the [ __ ] that
happened was real and some of the people
he talked to were real but the thing
about it is that i think the intention
of the movie and i'm pretty sure that
the intention of the movie was not to be
a conspiracy style mystery uh in that
form it was kind of like i think it's
more exploring how
the sort of like psychological fragility
engendered by grief or uncertainty
can lead a person kind of down these
paths of like unhealthy obsession where
they're starting to look for meaning
where there isn't any so they're finding
like all these meaningless deeds because
there's a lot of
stuff like that like peppered throughout
the film like as he goes along this you
know ride and talks to like all these
various people about what he thinks is
this big conspiracy many people like
kind of warn him off it like people say
things like that like oh you know maybe
nothing means anything or something like
that so i kind of feel like they're
going more into it as
because he doesn't have any closure over
what happened to his wife because she
just disappeared um and he really very
much wants closure so he's trying to
sort of like
find something that will give her
disappearance meaning he wants to find
out what happened to her and he just
really wants everything resolved and
tied up with a bow but life isn't really
like that
now i have seen and this is kind of like
spoiler territory although like i said
you can bring your own theories to it
because i don't think there's i don't
think there's any one particular answer
i think there could be a couple
different theories i'm kind of of the
opinion i thought the first time that i
watched it again spoiler alert spoiler
alert spoiler alert i kind of thought
after i finished watching it that james
had actually killed his wife
and couldn't
deal with it and like dissociated and
then was sort of like constructed most
of this sort of like conspiracy
which most of which was like built
around like real things like but he tied
all the tendrils together like in a way
that maybe absolved him and made it seem
like this bigger conspiracy but it works
either way i kind of feel like it could
be too that because she was found well
she wasn't found like what she
disappeared and all that was found was
her car and it was on a bridge it could
be and i've seen this theory uh kind of
put forth as well that she actually just
committed suicide and he can't really
deal with that either maybe thinking
that he's guilty for like causing her
like driving her to it because of
something that he did and there's kind
of hints toward that as well so it could
also go in that direction but largely i
don't think that this movie is saying
that all of this that all this
conspiracy stuff really happened
i think that it's more exploring the
psychological breakdown of a person who
can't deal like i said with grief with
uncertainty with not having closure what
happened to their loved one so they're
just constructing like you know uh this
big like edifice of meaning
when out of like meaningless things or
things that are not connected so it's
kind of like looking into
how people get sucked into this type of
stuff like how people get sucked into
conspiracy theories so i think it's kind
of like in that as i said i think maybe
sometimes like the ending might be
frustrating for some viewers but
if you
think about it
and if you watch this a second time and
like pick up on all these clues and like
all the things that some of the
characters say to him some of the things
that he says i kind of feel like it's
more like a psychological journey rather
than like a noir style mystery even
though it's presented
very much like a noir style mystery so
i mean if you're okay with all that um
with knowing that it's not going to be
resolved then i think you might uh kind
of dig it i mean you should probably
like take a look at it especially if
you're fascinated by those like creepy
like ominous like analog
videos with like cryptic origins like if
you're real into that kind of like args
like analog type ergs um then you'll
probably be into this because it's this
very much has that kind of like vibe to
it it's kind of this is kind of in the
same ballpark as movies like um the
conspiracy which came out in 2012 which
i think i reviewed uh it's a little bit
like sensor which i just talked about
not too long ago from 2021 and a little
bit like barbarian sound studio which is
also from 2012 which i also talked about
a while back so it's not exactly like
those but it's kind of in the same
ballpark as that so if you're into that
kind of stuff then this one is like is
definitely worth watching and like i
said it's one that i think i liked it
better
after i finished watching and i was like
thinking about it you know what i mean
like i was thinking about it and like
reading other uh you know taking notes
about it and stuff like that and i was
just kind of like oh i see so it's a lot
more clever than i thought it was like
at first blush i guess but as i said
your mileage is gonna vary but i ended
up enjoying it quite a bit um even
though i kind of like it better in
retrospect than it did i liked it a lot
when i was watching it but i think i
liked it better like the more i thought
about it and i definitely will be
rewatching this one again because this
definitely seems like another movie to
like kind of nerd out about which like i
said is funny because it's almost kind
of like a meta statement it's like this
guy like lost his [ __ ] marbles like
you know finding all these connections
or like looking at all these theories
and then it's almost kind of like
inviting you to do the same thing with
the movie itself which you know i was
like oh okay i see what you did that's
pretty cool but yeah it's definitely
worth watching it's on amazon prime
probably some other streaming services
as well
and that'll do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys on the next one
bye